[Music]
there's also a family affair on the set
of Angelina Jolie's Harper's Bazaar
cover shoot where Angelina once again
takes a walk on the wild side here in
Namibia for the 150th anniversary for
Harper's beaming like a bride and a
white strapless Versace and backless
Ralph Lauren
Angelina's struggle bows with some
rescue cheetah she's been sponsoring
since 2015 this country is a special
country to me because the shower was
born here but it's also a very special
country because it is one of the few
countries that is doing so much for the
environment also in this trip to Africa
Angelina and chai though opened a new
clinic for wounded and orphan animals
called the Shiloh Wildlife Sanctuary not
just look after the land but also very
close to the culture and how it all
connects
it seems the 42 year old is following in
two steps of her a good friend jane
goodall the more I learn the more I
realized Angelina was at the premiere of
the new documentary Jane this week and
says her children look up to the
wildlife activist the Harvest Bazaar
cover girl telling the magazine quote if
my life experience has taught me
anything it is only what you stand for
and what you choose to stand against
that defines you
[Music]
you